bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france 10% de variants anglais parmi les
cas contaminés en ile de france
le confinement est il désormais
inéluctable selon vous je pense que si
on reprend l'expression de l'allocution
de monsieur apple ou les juges de
nouveau peu insuffisant dans
l'efficacité
on a peut être une chance de justement
de passer au delà et d'avoir un coup
d'avancé pour la maladie cause id nous
en tant que soignant oui bien sûr on
envisage sérieusement et on a déjà un
petit peu comment canaliser un troisième
confinement voilà ces jeux j'écoute je
crois sincèrement même si j'ai pas là là
même si je suis pas médecin et même si
je n'ai pas de l'antériorité experts
pour avoir aidé décisionnel il ya
peut-être une carte à jouer pour la
population trentaine est en tout cas
pour les contenus doyen pente est
d'avoir une mainmise sur cette pandémie
et surtout maintenant sans cette
variante anglaise qui pendent est de
plus en plus contagieuse et nous on le
voit bien sur différents états défendent
ap-hp il ya des clusters kif en train de
se dessiner et de prêts destinés avec
des arguments pour anglaise
donc oui je vais je crois qu'il faut
aller sur un confinement ou métalangage
n'engage que moi et mais je crois qu'il
ya peut-être une possibilité de faire
quelque chose vous qui travaillait
justement henry vendeur un hôpital qui
situent en ile de france dans le val de
marne à créteil à quelle est la
situation actuelle dans cet hôpital y at
il une surcharge dans les services de
réanimation n'est pas la même que celle
qu'on a vécue et qu'on a subies lors de
la première la première crise sanitaire
avec le premier confinement mais très
clairement et très nettement les
chiffres sont à la hausse donc pour
l'instant c'est supportable de vue
sanitaire et des protège tout à l'heure
lorsque je vous disais il ya peut-être
une chance est en tout cas de 291 soins
confinement qui nous permettrai nous
entende personnel soignant et parthenay
le chiite allié de pouvoir de pouvoir
faire face en tout cas à une éventuelle
ont su comment je pourrais dire à un
tsunami de patients parce que ce qui
nous pose la problématique majeure
on rencontre est ce que tout le monde
rencontre et cette variante anglaise qui
semble avoir une contagiosité
de beaucoup plus importante que le
premier chrono virus auquel elle avait
été confrontée
et vous vous êtes favorable à un
compliment strictes qui entraînerait par
exemple la fermeture des écoles les
collèges et et déguisés comme comme on
l'a vécu au bas de mars air et dernier
c'est là qu'il ya un conflit entre qu'on
voudrait nous en tant que personnel
soignant et en même temps qu'il faut
pour battre pour les usagers au
quotidien c'est indéniable et je suis
d'accord avec tout le monde de dire que
pour les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans ou kate
une catastrophe mais qui éveille
dramatique ce kit pas toujours eu ces
mêmes dramatique pour les collégiens
thématiques pour tous les professionnels
qui travaillent pas dans les hôpitaux
donc il faut trouver la bonne solution
il faut trouver la bonne la bonne
stratégie
je pense que déjà la première des
stratégies ses forêts ses d'infantiliser
les protêts on a fait preuve de beaucoup
de résilience ont fait preuve de
beaucoup de d'efforts quand je vois que
certains avant droite pour interdit
parce que pour du mazout est que ce team
parce que là et que le matin dans les
métros on est sous mon nez et on est
bondée de monde
oui il ya gars ce qu'on voudrait faire
de dans l'imaginaire et que les français
rencontrent au quotidien donc il faut
trouver la bonne stratégie
je sais pas honnêtement nu en tout
enfant de personnel soignant en tous les
cas on ne voudrait pas revivre ce qu'on
a vécu sur le premier compliment qui
nous a est ce qui a été très martyrisant
pour tous les personnels hospitaliers et
les ports tenait le soignant voilà c'est
très très compliqué je pense qu'il faut
trouver la meilleure des solutions est
pour le coup il faut en parler avec les
élus municipaux les élus des régions les
élus on fera la forme mais aussi parce
que c'est des porte-parole des navires
ont parlé aussi avec les et comment les
représentants hospitalier voilà il ya il
ya matière à débattre des frais
rapidement on a peut-être une chance de
ne pas se laisser submerger par cette
variante longue elle est la dernière
question rapidement vous en avait parlé
à voulait pas revivre un premier
confinement qui était être très
difficile à gérer pour vous est-ce que
vous vous sentez mieux préparée par
rapport à ses deux premiers confinement
est ce que les moyens déployés sont
s'ils sont suffisants selon vous pour
l'instant les moyens déployés on y
travaille au quotidien avec on espère
quand même plus
les gouvernements et les directeurs des
hôpitaux et aura pour le coup moi en ce
qui concerne la direction générale de la
dépense publique hôpitaux de paris a
pris les mesures est en tout cas à
préparer un éventuel au dessus des
militaires sur lequel on a été on a été
dévasté on va envoyer les prêts terme on
a été dévastée nous sourit henri mondor
on a servi d'établissement au plan com
pour la république en marge puisque je
vous rappelle qu'on a été
l'établissement c'était un bâtiment qui
a été étatisé pour faire face au
quotidien
alors j'ai envie de vous dire j'espère
qu'on est matériellement prêt
physiquement et psychologiquement on est
un petit peu moins
d'autant plus que là on vient d'être
confronté à une aot à une décision ainsi
peiner latéral unilatérale qui je vous
cache pas nous nous a littéralement mis
ko debout parce que on vient de perdre
une
une discipline experte pour nous est
très importante qui est la grèce la
grèce de 30 mentions and cardiac voyez
on vient de l'apprendre il ya quelques
jours
voyez et toute cette actualité sanitaire
fait que sont l'hôpital au rwanda on est
un petit peu ko debout donc on va faire
face à la maladie covin il faut rassurer
tous les citoyens
je crois qu'il vient et surtout belle de
marne et deux on est un peu comme
sylviane bourdeix on est un petit peu ko
debout avec des décisions priment de
perdre la présentation aux cardiaques
ici l'ouest des localités hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière
là on n'a pas compris cette stratégie
mais je crois qu'on doit rassurer les
français ignorent que le personnel
soignant investira encore il sera à
hauteur des missions de service public
là pour le coup on demande à nos
dirigeants de nous remettre la grèce
pour la greffe cardiaque pardon et de
pouvoir travailler dans les meilleures
conditions pour remplir notre mission de
service public sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous sur
arte français erythrée que je rappelle
que vous êtes délégué syndical sud santé
infirmier anesthésiste à l'hôpital henri
mondor dans le val de marne